Our final speaker against the motion identity politics is tearing
society apart. David Lammy, labor MP for Tottenham.
One of Parliament's most prominent campaigners for social justice
famously led the recent campaign for the Windrush generation to be granted
British citizenship. He's fought for justice for the Grenfell tower families.
And of course has run the high profile campaign calling on Oxbridge to
improve access for students from underrepresented and disadvantaged
backgrounds. David, the floor is yours.
[Inaudible].
So I'm listening to the speakers and I'm
thinking about a young David Lammy
growing up in Tottenham in the 1970s.
It's the young David Lammy that looks like Michael Jackson and wants to be
Michael Jackson.
And that young David Alami would never have believed
that the tide of human progress would bring
me here in front of you able to
articulate, to speak, to have the confidence to do that.
I was also thinking of another young,
but a bit older David lobby who walked into the house of commons
at the beginning of that Tony Blair government.
By that point, I look more like Denzel Washington.
This was a period of consensus.
Politics.
Clinton, Blair,
new labor things were coming together.
We had 10 consecutive quarters of growth and the
kind of cool Brittania emerged,
where there were a lot of drugs as well and things, but you know,
dance music, but people loved one another.
Here I am 2019.
I now look like forest Whitaker
Tomorrow.
People will be voting in the European elections and
many will vote for what I see as
hard, right? Parties and positions.
This is an age of Trump,
of Farage of Jacob Reese, [inaudible] of Boris Johnson.
And we are accusing identity politics of
tearing society.
The great story of the 20th century
was probably democracy,
but if there is a second story theme that ox
that century surely it is rights.
And that by the end of that century,
so many human beings who started off at the beginning of the 20th
century,
subjugated oppressed could actually begin to self
actualize in their own lifetimes.
Women got the vote and with the invention of the
pill control over their own bodies,
ethnic minorities, colonized,
you remember those pink bits of the Atlas over so much of the world
broke off because of the powerful words and behavior of
people like Gandy from that colonization workers
came from being exploited,
burst movements like the labor party.
And I still believe at its best,
the best progressive cause in our country and
now same sex marriage and those who are
LGBT taking their place when it's only in
1967,
that you could be imprisoned because of the person that you
love. That is a remarkable story.
The story that is the story of the 20th century.
And of course that is a story about identity because
when Martin Luther King spoke and he talked about judging
somebody by the character
of their soul, not by the color of their skin,
have we arrived at that?
And even though that was a goal, even though that was a goal,
he didn't park his identity at the door to get that
goal.
And neither did Harvey milk fighting for gay rights in
San Francisco and beyond,
and all those fighting for disability rights. So for me,
identity politics is about empathy.
It is about dignity and my God,
I look Nigel Farage in the face and I say,
it's about compassion,
compassion for your fellow human B.
So we stand buying that progress despite all that we
have to do.
And now in a period where those on the right dismiss,
when I raised concerns about who should
lead the inquiry into those poor people,
that right, desperate knit included a friend of mine,
the 20th floor of Grenfell tower burned to death,
a young woman called Khadija se.
And I raised questions about who should lead that inquiry because
actually in the role that I play in public life,
someone should say this,
it has to another white male
privileged class judge,
not because he can't do a good job,
Joe scam and did a good job when he led the riots into the Brixton riots.
But is there not in Britain in 2019,
an ethnic minority lawyer,
or even a woman that could take that role.
And I say that at a point in our country,
we're only 7% of the judges are from an ethnic minority
background. And we have one,
one woman on our Supreme court progress so
much more, so much more to do.
And those on the left of course,
class and economic equality inequality
have to be challenged. That's the basis of my politics.
But those who fight for rights today do not stand
opposed to issues of inequality
that exists in our society.
Just as there were LGBT people who set up solid,
these parity funds to fight for the minors.
You can be alongside those in that battle for
against inequality in our society. And yes,
there are moments when it goes too far.
If you're tweeting or writing white people or trash
kill all men that is identity politics that I would not want to
associate myself with,
but let us be clear on the proposition.
Let us really single in on what may be tearing
our society apart.
Populism might well be tearing our society
apart,
populism on the hard right and populism on the hard left
austerity cuts,
brutal cuts to local authorities right up and down the country.
The biggest North South divide since 1911,
that may be tearing our society apart,
grim poverty,
chronic housing conditions right across this city.
That means so many people who could be in this audience.
Aren't in this audience that could be tearing our society
apart, gross inequality
with 44% of the goo case wealth owned by just
10% of our population.
50% of the land in the UK owned by 1% of the
population that could be the proposition that could be tearing
our society apart.
But instead this proposition asks you blame the Bangladeshi
woman,
blame the trans man play me individual with disability,
and then they say their victims.
And we heard that language from Laila victim hood.
The victim hood that is being manipulated in our country is a victim
hood. That's being peddled today by Nigel Farage.
It is not the victim hood of the people I just described.
So reject this proposition.
It is not tearing our society apart.
It's an arc that begins with people like
Mandela, Martin Luther King Gandy,
Emily Pancras stand alongside it because in the age
that we are in, there is a big difference between dignity,
compassion,
and human rights and the populism that would rip our country a
Sunday.
[Inaudible].